[Música]
mi nombre es scott tengo 30 años y
trabajo en una empresa del gobierno me
llamo elena tengo 28 años y soy
estudiante de doctorado de terapia
ocupacional de la ufc soy hillary tengo
22 y soy niñera soy jane y dirijo una
agencia de diseño y tengo 29 años
soy dominican dre tengo 28 años y soy
creador de contenido cuando escuché que
era creador de contenido supuse que
'quedan lo hacía por diversión
uno de ellos tiene millones en el banco
y no sé quién es que hacen en su tiempo
libre salgo patinar salgo con mis amigos
me gusta construir como he tenido
animales como reptiles construyó jaulas
ayudo a mis amigos a remodelar su casa
eso y tú
sólo salgo con mis amigos y como me mudé
los ángeles en mayo el gastado dinero en
entradas para el cine salidas y cosas
así la verdad es que no hago muchas
cosas no he viajado en 15 años cada vez
que tengo tiempo libre compró un boleto
de avión y me voy a algún sitio tan
pronto como cumplí 17 años un viaje
atrás yo también es genial nos va a ser
es mi pasión si cuando la vi pensé que
ella tenía dinero esta chica tiene
dinero es por su energía es lo que está
usando a alguien no te dice que tan rico
o qué tan pobre es por ejemplo lo que
uso todo este atuendo no pasa de 100
dólares empecé a hacer una licenciatura
en filosofía y en ciencias políticas y
después hice un máster en relaciones
internacionales con enfoque en el
conflicto de oriente medio luego trabajé
como terapeuta de salud mental tenía que
hacer 3.000 horas casi gratis y luego
llegó el cob y di fue cuando hice la
transición a tiempo completo en las
redes sociales empecé a trabajar con eso
esa es mi carrera qué buen currículo
[Risas]
de 2000 dólares en préstamos
estudiantiles
vaya he trabajado como niñera desde hace
un tiempo tengo unos cinco años tal vez
y luego me mudé a esta ciudad aquí en
mayo mi nuevo trabajo es como asistente
personal de un artista de maquillaje de
una celebridad que acabo de empezar pero
todavía trabajo como niñera yo acabo de
terminar mi maestría cuando recibí este
diploma estaba muy feliz y ahora hago el
doctorado pero eso solamente un año tuve
la suerte de conseguir una buena beca en
la ufc también estoy en el ejército
medio tiempo es otra fuente de ingresos
fui a una escuela de manejo de animales
exóticos
para animales
también trabajó para una empresa de
servicios públicos soy lector de
medidores el área de los animales no es
muy estable incluso estuve en la
industria del entretenimiento con
animales y no es para mí me gusta la
estabilidad de un trabajo en el gobierno
hice mi doble maestría en negocios
internacionales
y se en purdue en una escuela de
negocios en francia y luego empecé mi
propia empresa hace casi cinco años y
medio de que es la empresa de diseño de
software y tiene un negocio exitoso que
tiene más de cinco años estudió en
francia me pareció que estaba muy cómoda
en lo económico
[Música]
dominique mencionaste que tienes deudas
quizás no tienes mucho dinero por eso te
pondré con el número 5 todavía estudia
cellay na creo que la beca te da
suficiente dinero pero no mucho serás el
número 4
hillary el número 3 me pondré el número
2 guillén y te pondré el número 1 le
daré a dominique el 5 también me pondré
a mí en el número 4 en el número 3
pondré a scott y luego en el número 2 a
hillary parece que tienes buenas
conexiones para llegar a trabajar con un
artista famosa pero sólo lo asumo y allí
ni le daré el 1 porque eres dueña de una
empresa y dijiste que en tu tiempo libre
siempre te vas de viaje yo voy a
comenzar
conmigo en el 5 dominique en el 4 scott
en el 3 número 2 y lena y en el número 1
pondría jim y me gusta el número 1
[Risas]
voy a empezar con hillary en el 5 sólo
porque eres y acabas de cambiar de
trabajo en el 4 pondré y lena el 3 es
para scott para ti de hecho creo que
eres como dice
y luego supongo que me pondré en el
número 1 en realidad pensé que dominique
estaría en el primer lugar porque sé que
los creadores de contenido si eres bueno
pueden hacer mucho dinero bien a ti el
número 5 estuviste en el ejército y
estás en la reserva con esos estudios
seguro tenistas te para que te pagarán
los estudios lo que significa que no
tenías mucho dinero entonces 5 y tú el 4
scott tienes un buen trabajo en el
gobierno por eso te daré el número 3 y a
ti te daré el número 1 y a mí el número
2 yo sólo pensaba que no quería ser el
primero en especial si me equivocaba de
todas formas no creo que alguien tenga
millones en el banco
[Música]
i
en el número 5 tenemos a elena con dos
mil dólares en el banco mis padres eran
muy jóvenes mi madre tenía 16 años y mi
padre 18 y por eso no ahorraron para que
pudiera ir a la universidad tuve que
esforzarme mucho para tener becas las
becas me ayudan pero tengo una deuda de
seis cifras en el número cuatro tenemos
a hillary con siete mil dólares en el
banco en el número tres tenemos a scott
con 215 mil dólares en el banco lo ven
para mí dos mil dólares es una buena
cantidad me siento útil y al schlosser
eso pensé oh cielos somos lo sé no sé en
el número dos tenemos allí ni
480 dólares en el banco vaya
y en el número 1 tenemos a dominique con
600.000 dólares en el banco
[Música]
este año gane todo mi dinero en enero me
hablaron de snap chat que suelen pagar
bien los mejores vídeos gane un millón
de dólares el mes pasado mi último vídeo
es el de la identificación falsa de la
roca
dominique me engañó no estoy en todas
las redes sociales solo en facebook
cuando dijo que era un creador de
contenido no significó mucho para mí por
eso lo puse al final podría ser dinero
de la familia podría ser un billete de
lotería o lo que sea nunca se sabe
[Música]